we're continuing to push into the
meaning of environment so we've gone
from physical environments to virtual
environments and I'm very very
interested in these new emerging
environments such as social networking
sites which are places which are very
interesting places for us projecting our
identity but also reflecting our
behavior so the sorts of behaviors that
go on there I think are very interesting
not you know not frivolous and trivial
as they often are claimed to be and also
virtual spaces to what's going there
because there we don't have constraints
most of us have constraints in what we
in the source of places we can create
virtual spaces less so and so I think
looking the connections between people's
real environments in the virtual
environments is a you know a holds many
opportunities to understand what's going
on inside our heads you know people
often say well why do what do people use
facebook for what do people use a second
life for and the answer if they use it
for a whole bunch of different things
you know there are many different
purposes you know and i think i think is
it's reasonable to to predict that
people in these spaces will both try to
create extensions of themselves but also
experiment with other other possible
selves